hey what is up guys and capacity here
and for a while the whole SmartWatch
game was all about pebble and I had a
pebble for a long time but now Android
wear is a thing and it's kind of taken
over the whole SmartWatch game so let's
go ahead and take a deep dive but what
exactly Android wear is what it does and
why you should care so the entire point
of smartwatches is to give you
information at a glance and these
Android wear smartwatches do this by
giving you Google now cards and your
phone's notifications on your wrist so
all of the Google now cards you'd get
show up here and any app that would
ordinarily show you notifications like
messages or an email or something those
notifications will now show up on your
wrist too and the way you navigate
through all these is with swipes it's
all laid out in a cards UI and basically
any notification that was expandable
where you can tap on it or expand to get
more info on your phone you can now tap
and expand to get more info on your
watch - sometimes I gets you more
information out of like a google mount
weather card other times it lets you
take action like play or pause music or
archive an email or do something like
that and your watch is connected to your
phone through bluetooth so they talk to
each other seamlessly and really fast so
when you dismiss a notification on your
watch for example it also gets dismissed
from your phone pretty quickly and
vice-versa
on top of all of that it also has these
customizable watch faces so since it is
a watch or tell them the time anyway so
you glance at it and you get a bunch of
different watch faces it varies from
watch to watch so you'll get a different
set of faces depending on which model
you get but it basically just lights up
when you get a new notification or when
you activate it yourself and then just
for a little extra just a little extra
on top it is its own full-fledged
operating system so they also have some
standalone features - most of which can
be voice-activated because it does have
a microphone in it so the first thing
it'll do since it'll talk to Google keep
on your phone is it'll take a note so if
you say take a note then it will write
down whatever you say in Google keep
next you have reminders so it'll set an
alarm to remind you to do something at a
time or location it also has a pedometer
which I'll talk about later in a second
but you can show your own steps then you
can send a text or an email to anyone in
your contacts list again just by
dictating it and you also have your
agenda for your day in Google Calendar
and you
navigate to a nearby place or location
by telling it to you can set a timer or
start a stopwatch for a certain amount
of time and the alarm will go off on the
phone and it also vibrate when it's done
you can set an alarm or show all the
alarms you have and again those will
also vibrate on the watch and then you
have your settings and then you can also
start a third-party app so there are a
couple of third-party apps that are
built-in so you can just say start
tinder and then you can just start using
tinder on your phone and there are a
couple of third-party apps that are
available in the Play Store right now
that are compatible with Android wear
they will talk to your watch and again
you can literally start and open them up
right on your watch and use them without
even having your phone out of your
pocket now even though it may seem
awkward and geeky to tap your watch and
then start talking to it because it is
it actually works pretty well for the
most part and I got used to swiping
motions pretty fast it also has a quick
swipe down gesture from the top so if
you're driving or something and you
don't want it to be distracting you can
silence all the notifications until you
unmute it and in my daily life I think
it's really nice to not constantly be
checking your phone in and out of your
pocket to get notifications I actually
loved having the pebble for that but I
also used some of the watch's standalone
features like I talked about for example
the timer I use it to set a timer for
myself a couple times while cooking just
something I wanted to have it remind me
of to check on something
it works well also just has a subtle
vibration on your wrist when it's done
it's not like jarring or anything I also
use it to send messages especially when
driving so I literally just say okay
Google and then dictate whatever message
I want to send and the recipient and
again will just get the message as if I
sent it via a regular text message never
have to take my hands off the wheel or
be distracted reminders I didn't use as
much but let's say I wanted to remember
something I just say ok Google remind me
to buy water at 4 p.m. and then BOOM
now we should note this is the first
version of Android wear so I see a lot
of room for improvement a lot of places
work and get better and I don't even
really think the average person is going
to like this stuff yet but for a real
geek like a tech head like me this stuff
is awesome I get a ton of use out of it
the Google now cards especially I had a
Google now card with my boarding pass a
couple of weeks ago to get on a flight
and I
literally scanned my watch to get on the
plane instead of a physical boarding
pass that kind of stuff blows the
people's mind sometimes and right now
it's still in that stage where it's a
bit of a geek toy instead of a
mainstream gadget and also right now
only a couple of devices are running
Android where there's this LGG watch
I've shown for the whole video which is
my current choice and then there's the
Samsung gear live which is almost
exactly the same with a bit of a
different design and they both have
their weird quirks being first-gen
devices like a lack of buttons on the G
watch or an interesting charging cradle
for the Samsung watch the circular and
badass moto 360 that is coming later
this summer and I definitely think
that's going to be the one to get your
hands on if you're a regular person and
you just want to get into Android wear
for the first time and I could also see
Google glass running Android wear
eventually too but really you got to
think about the downsides the biggest
downside right now
it's got to be battery life I mean the G
watch last 36 hours on battery a day and
a half if you literally don't touch it
once but with regular use you're using
it a lot you're checking it it's dead by
the end of the day and you have to
charge it every night which isn't a big
deal since it doesn't die in the middle
of the day but it's still a bit annoying
that it only lasts one day on battery
and then the fact that it's so new we
have to wait for some more dedicated
watch apps to hit the Play Store I think
they'll really make it pop the apps that
use it well right now that are well
integrated are phenomenal and look great
and sound great and function really well
but outside of that there aren't too
many now I do have to note that the
pedometer that uses to to count your
steps is actually in the watch itself it
doesn't seem to be using the pedometer
in the phone you're connected to and
because of that you tend to take a lot
of steps by accident just by moving your
wrist and it just counts because it
thinks you took a step so if I was
reaching my daily goal of 10,000 steps
per day it was because I took 900 while
eating breakfast or while throwing or
while brushing my teeth or whatever it
was just counting steps all the time
when I wasn't actually walking writing
an essay taking notes in class it was
counting steps so I wouldn't quite base
my fitness routine or any goals I have
on the pedometer and any Android
SmartWatch at least for now so that is
Android wear it's a little bit of a
combination of like we said Google now
and your phone's notifications on your
wrist is
available for iOS at all yet it's not
available for Windows Phone at all yet
just for people who have an Android
phone and an Android wear SmartWatch so
to me the bottom line is it's still kind
of hard to convince the masses to buy a
SmartWatch whether it's Android wear or
the next Apple SmartWatch or a pebble or
something else it's just people who
don't wear watches in the first place
aren't really flocking to buy any
smartwatches right now so it's kind of
hard to tell what I would say is wait
for the Moto 360 wait to check out the
more high-end ones that come out wait
for the Apple option of course and those
that follow the Apple option and I think
in the second half of this year in the
first half of 2015 we're going to get a
lot more awesome smartwatches especially
out of this Android wear stuff because
at the beginning of a proof-of-concept
that's really cool looking and I think
once functionality gets built in with
more third-party apps and more people
start to take advantage of the fact that
they can build apps for the wrist it's
going to be a lot more awesome so this
has been my Android wear experience and
review thank you for watching feel free
to give it a thumbs up if you enjoyed it
and subscribe there's a subscribe button
below if you haven't clicked out already
to see more videos like this one they
come out again thanks for watching I'll
talk to you guys the next one bass